not many people are aware of the genuine
mechanics behind how my rating system
works i judge a work of art a book a
novel based on the criteria of
characters locations settings cities
states themes why so much focus on
location now statistically a work of
fiction that is set on mars is bound to
be superior to any work of fiction set
on the planet earth a good character as
we all know is one who knows how to take
action uh the most physically violent
and dominant are typically the best
characters period jack bauer on the show
24 is one of the canonically best
characters ever written every great
rating system must rest on the legacy
that is the siskel and ebert uh rating
system four star or thumbs up well i use
both two star that means one thumb up
one thumb neutral four stars is two
thumbs up maybe the most important part
is do any of the fictional elements any
way relate to the song you can call me
al by paul simon now by this metric if
any film features a man who walks down
the street he says why am i why am i
soft in the middle why am i soft in the
middle the rest of my life is so hard i
need a photo opportunity i need a shot
of redemption i don't want to end up a
car
tune in a cartoon graveyard bone digger
bone digger dogs in the moonlight far
away from the well door mr beer belly
beer belly get this uh
mut away from you know i don't find this
stuff amusing anymore now if you'll be
my bodyguard i can be your long-lost pal
i can call you betty but betty if you
call me you can call me al again any
characters named better betty or al are
immediately suspect anyone who is
obviously soft in the middle and i don't
mean in a physical way i mean in a
character way that's going to pose a
serious problem in summary we have the
thumbs the four star you can call me al
rating system all of these elements
combined create a perfect
algorithm all the critics use it jeremy
jeremy jeremy jones uses it if you are
interested in using this rating system
email me at rating.email.aol.com
obviously you're gonna have to pay some
licensing fees you're going to get 100
accurate reviews of all works of art if
you use this i want to thank all of my
patrons who
stick through to the end thank you
[Music]